Today I'm going to tell you something about
circles, okay. So you know some things in math we
do because like we're trying to solve a problem,
right, like we want to get a rocket ship to the
moon or whatever; and some things in math we do
because we've just been doodling on a piece of
paper and wondering what's going on. So this is
more in the like paper doodling category. Here's
the basic question: can I fill up let's say an
infinite sheet of paper with circles? The way that
I've said this to you this seems really obvious
right? Like I just draw a bunch of circles, I
can draw as many as I want, I cover the entire
sheet of paper. But if I impose some rule, like
say I don't want any two of the circles to touch
each other, right, to like overlap or even share a
single point in common then this is a much less
obvious question. This is called a partition by
the way, when we don't allow them to touch each
other. The very first thing I'm going to have to
do is draw one circle. So once I've drawn this one
circle then I have actually now two questions to
ask. One is, can I cover up the the inside of the
circle with circles? The other is can I cover up
the outside of the circle with circles. Now one
of those two questions is actually pretty easy
to solve. If I want to cover up the outside of
the circle with circles I can just do this. So
take the same center for all my circles and just
increase the radius - of course you want to imagine
that I'm doing this for every possible size of
circle bigger than my first one. But that'll cover
up the entire outside of the first circle that I
drew. And since trying to answer this question
always starts with a first circle we can always
do this sort of infinite piece of the paper is
not really any problem. So the question really
then is I have this disc inside of a circle;
how can I cover it up with a bunch of circles
that don't touch each other? The first thing
you might want to do is just like on the outside
just shrink your circle sizes to cover up all of
the points inside of this disc. There's a little
problem with that plan, which is what happens
at the end of that game right? So we have these
smaller circles but but we're never going to get
a circle that covers this center point. But you
say well well well well well, I only tried this
particular covering of the disc, so maybe instead
why don't I put like a circle here and a circle
there and maybe a circle like this with different
centers and different sizes. It turns out that the
answer is that you actually cannot do this, okay?
You are always going to miss at least one point
when you try to cover the inside of a circle, so
the disc, with circles that don't touch each
other. And the reason why is because of almost
exactly the same thing that goes wrong with my
red circles. If I start trying to cover a disc
like this with circles; well let's think about
this center point. If I can cover this disc with
circles, that center point has to live on one of
them. Now the circle that it lives on, whatever it
is say this big, it can't be too large right? Cos if
the the width of the circle, the diameter of this
circle, was large enough then it would run into my
first circle. So that forces a size restriction
on the circle containing this center point. But
that second circle has its own center point; so
we draw the center there and that's got to be
in some circle to but it has to have pretty small
width as well. And so when I keep looking at these
centers, whatever circles they lie on, the widths
are getting smaller and smaller and smaller and
so we're all shrinking down. And at the end of the
process we're going to end up with a single point
here, just like in the original example, that cannot
lie on any of the circles. All right, so we cannot
cover this plane right, this 2-dimensional space,
with circles. Why don't we add a dimension and work
with space instead? Once you do that you can cover
the entire 3-dimensional space with circles.
It's not going to have some sort of simplification
like this where I cut it into an infinite piece
and a finite piece; because if I think about a
circle living in space - right I've got everything
sort of all around my circle, I don't have two
separate pieces that the circle cuts space into
okay. But this is actually to our benefit. So let
me show you how to do this.
We're moving to 3
dimensions we need a whole new piece of paper.
Right so here's say 2 dimensions and here is
my magical coming out of the paper third dimension.
If I think about a 3- a 2-dimensional sphere
living in our 3-dimensional space, right
so you know like a globe or something, just the
surface of a globe. If I remove two points from
that sphere then I get something that I can cover
with circles. So here's my best sphere, let's take
away these two points okay. I'm going to partition
my sphere into circles just by drawing circles
around these missing points. Again there's lots
and lots of these, infinitely many of them, but
hopefully you can see that they sort of stack
on top of each other to hit every point on the
sphere that's not one of my two x's. So this is
the- the trick that we're going to use: any sphere
when we we get rid of two points can be covered by
circles. We're going to take our 3-dimensional
space and I'm going to put some initial circles on
there. So let's put some coordinates. All right so
I'm going to draw an initial set of circles in my
3-dimensional space; but actually it's just
going to be like in those first two dimensions,
I'm not even going to think about the direction
coming out of the paper yet. So here's one and
here's another one. Supposed to be a circle! Okay so
all these are of width 2, radius 1 circles with
centers on these integer coordinate points, right.
So I've got these circles sort of spaced out on
the flat part of my 3-dimensional space. How
this helps me now is if I draw a sphere centered
at the red point here, okay, then let's think
about how my red sphere that I drew hits the
black circles that I drew first. The black circles
all live in this flat part of space, given you know
the desktop or the brown paper right. And so the
circles on the brown paper, the sphere that I drew
will only touch the circles exactly where it hits
the brown paper too, right? So I want to think about
slicing my sphere off right by where the brown
paper is. And look at what happened here, so how
many points did I hit any of my black circles?
I hit two points. That was just for the example
that I drew, but actually if you sort of stare at
my construction, the location of my circles were
chosen very carefully so that any sphere that
I draw, that's centered at this red point, will
hit exactly twice one of the black circles. And
so that's how I get my circle covering of this
3-dimensional space. First I draw this family
of black circles, they go on in every direction, and
then I draw every single sphere that's centered
at this red point. Now any of those spheres can
then be covered by circles by themselves and so
each of those spheres can be covered by all of
these circles and putting them all together I get
a way to cover the entire 3-dimensional space
with circles. Then you might ask, why am I caring so
much about circles? A circle after all is just like
the collection of points in a 2-dimensional
space which are some fixed distance away from
a center. Well that's actually what a sphere is
too if I'm in 3-dimensional space instead of
2-dimensional space. So maybe the right question
to ask is can I cover 3-dimensional space with
spheres that don't touch each other? In fact for
almost exactly the same reason that we couldn't
do the 2-dimensional space with circles you
cannot cover the 3-dimensional space with
2-dimensional spheres. You're always going to
have something left. no matter what you try to do.
2-dimensional spheres can be used to cover
5-dimensional space but this very simple- well okay,
a little complicated but if you stare at it for
a little while it's not so bad. This very simple
construction for circles in R3 has not so far
provided a guide for how we might might expand
that up a dimension for spheres in R4, right?
4-dimensional space. In general I think the
question is is not completely known about if you
take a sphere in some number of dimensions and
you take a space of some number of dimensions,
when can you say it's possible to partition
the space into spheres of that dimension?
Whatare the prime divisors of each element of this
sequence look like?
- That seems like a harderquestion!
- Well it might be a harder question
depending on how specific you want to get. But so
what I mean by the prime divisors of elements of
the sequence is we have these factors, so each
number factors into prime numbers as long as
we're ignoring zero here. So 3 is already
prime; so this is actually a really good point
this is exactly what I want to talk about, is that
if you just randomly do this - choose some number C....